The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So misconceptions.
So misconceptions, alternative
conceptions, understanding the
student view of the world,
why is that important?
Well one of the best ways to
introduce the importance of
the idea is a story.
Now I'm not 100% sure the story
is true, but it's so
good that it ought to be
true even if it isn't.
I think it is actually true.
So this was two, let's say
physics, TAs, physics grad
students, who were in
a philosophy class.
And the teacher in the
philosophy class said well--
they were talking about things
being relative, and morals
being relatives, and relativity
in philosophy--
as an example of relativity,
and things being relative
depending on the situation, if
you drop a pencil on the
Earth, it will fall
to the ground.
But if you drop the pencil
on the moon, it
won't fall to the ground.
It will just float.
And so most of the people in
the class just nodded,
basically thinking, oh that's
a good example.
But the two physicists in the
class were a bit shocked and
said well wait a minute,
wait a minute.
That can't be true.
Surely, something
is wrong here.
So they raised their hand.
They said, well wait a minute.
If you drop a pencil on the
moon, surely it's going to
fall to the ground, to the
ground of the moon.
And the other people in
the class said, no,
no, that's not right.
That's not right.
So they thought, OK, well we
have some way of convincing
them that the pencil's
not going to float.
And they said, OK well you all
saw the pictures of the
astronauts walking on
the moon, right?
And they said, oh yeah.
Well, when the astronauts walk,
did they just float
away, or did they stay
on the moon?
Oh, they stayed on the moon.
Well, how'd that happen?
They thought, oh we
have them now.
And what was the response?
The response was, oh, well
that was because the
astronauts were wearing
heavy boots.
So here was a chance to do a bit
of educational research.
So they thought, oh my god.
Maybe is this just this class?
Let's actually do a survey.
So they took out the university
phone directory and
just randomly dialed people.
And they called them up and
said, OK if you drop a pencil
on the moon, will
it float away or
will fall to the ground?
And most of the people said,
it's going to float away.
So then they said, oh yeah, but
what about the astronauts?
And they gave them the
whole thing about
the astronauts again.
And about half of the people
said, oh yeah, that's because
the astronauts were wearing
heavy boots.
So again, they were shocked
and flabbergasted.
And I think that reaction is
a very healthy reaction.
But what it shows is
that the students--
so in this case they weren't
officially their students--
but students--
they could easily be
your students--
can have a very different view
of the world, of the physical
world, than you have.
And if that's true, that means
that as you're teaching them,
what you're teaching is actually
being interpreted in
this completely different way.
I think Goethe said that--
he said that mathematicians,
or maybe it was Frenchmen.
It was either Frenchmen
or mathematicians.
Maybe it was mathematicians.
They have their own language,
and everything you tell them,
they first translate into their
own language, and only
then do they understand it.
So that's the same thing.
The students are translating the
things you're saying into
their own language.
But to understand what they're
translating into, you have to
know what their language is.
So in other words, you have
to understand not just the
misconceptions, but in general
the conceptions that students
have, so that you can actually
plan your teaching.
And here is a diagram
to illustrate that.
So this is a model of teaching
to see where all
the pieces fit in.
So here, this is the system,
which is how students think.
This is the output, which is
what students can do after
they go through our teaching.
And this is the input, which
is what we do, what kind of
classroom structure we set up,
what assignments we do.
And by this, I mean how students
think individually
and collectively, how students
work together, as well.
So generally speaking
the way--
so this is the system.
And call this the result.
And this is the teaching.
Our problem is trying to figure
out the teaching.
And how do you figure
out the teaching?
Well you start with figuring
out what result you want.
What do you want students
to be able to do?
What is your goal
for the class?
And then you have to run it
back through the system.
Right so you figure out the
result, and you run it through
the inverse of s.
And then there's
your teaching.
That's the teaching equation
let's call it.
Now those of you from
engineering fields know that
basically the only thing
you can do anything
with is linear systems.
And unfortunately anything
that's even slightly non
linear basically is a bag of
tricks, and there's nothing
you can do.
And you're just hosed.
Well unfortunately this system
is incredibly non-linear.
So it's probably kind of hard to
work out s inverse, even if
you can work out r.
But it's hard, but it doesn't
mean you can't start.
And a necessary condition for
even doing anything in this
direction is you have to
know what is in s,
how do students think.
Another necessary condition
is you need to work out r.
And that's actually
something--
what is the result you want?
So that we're going to
talk about in the
session on course design.
That's something that's often
forgotten in teaching, and
it's fundamentally important.
That if you don't plan your
goals, if you don't plan where
you want to go, your chance of
getting there is pretty low.
So assume you've done that.
The next thing you want to do is
you want to understand how
students think, so that you
can plan your teaching to
reach them, in other words,
so you have some chance of
working out s inverse.
Now you can't actually write
down some equation for s
inverse, but you can invert
it mentally in your head.
And a necessary condition for
doing that is to understand s.
So you want to understand where
students are coming
from, so that you
can work out t.
So that's the signals and
systems model of teaching.
Now, an example again to show
the importance of doing that
and what happens if you don't
actually understand where the
student's are is yet another
example from freshman physics.
I'll leave this here.
So this is one of the examples
from the readings.
So not everyone may have
read that reading.
It's the reading by Reif.
And it's this problem.
So this is a pendulum at
five points in its arc.
So these are the endpoints.
And the question people were
asked was to draw the
acceleration vector at
these five locations.
So what's the acceleration
right here, here,
here, here, and here?
So I'm not so interested in what
the actual answer is as
so much as how people
did on this.
So this is actually
really shocking.
So of students in intro
physics who've had
acceleration--
so they'd done acceleration--
zero out of 124 students
could do that problem.
So that's 0%.
So of grad TAs, it was 15%.
So these are grad TAs in physics
who TA that course.
And PhD students--
so was PhD students on their
qualifying exam.
It went up to 22%.
OK so now this is a
fundamentally important idea,
acceleration.
But you'd expect PhD students
on their qualifying
exam to be at 100%.
And you'd like the TAs in the
course to be at 100%.
Because there's no chance of
them teaching the students an
idea that they themselves
don't understand.
As Polya said, there's no
method of teaching yet
invented that will allow the
students to understand what
their teacher does not.
And that's true.
There's no amount of sort of
trickery with style and things
you can do to convey
an understanding
that you don't have.
So this is a very shocking
number to me.
And--
AUDIENCE: Who said that?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: George Polya.
So Polya was a great mathematics
teacher from
Hungary and then eventually
at Stanford.
And he's written--
I'll put references to his
books on the website.
But they are some of the
best books on math
teaching ever written.
And so he said that in
one of his books.
And it's I think very true.
So what this example shows is
that, a, the teachers didn't
understand it.
But that really fundamental
ideas can be completely
skipped over for years
and years and years.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's a special
example of some vague,
conceptually difficult
problem.
I'm just wondering-- so
I read the article.
Did they focus on how to
figure the answer out?
Because a lot of physics
majors don't.
PROFESSOR: OK, so the
question is, how
difficult is this problem?
It's an interesting problem,
because it's difficult if you
try to do it by just blasting
out the equations.
So they actually asked
a bunch of faculty
members the same question.
And one of them just got
completely tangled in knots,
physics faculty, trying to write
out the differential
equation and figure
out what the
acceleration is by brute force.
So yeah, it is hard if
you do it that way.
But if you actually
understand--
I'll show you--
what the acceleration means,
then it's no problem.
So for example, here, the
thing isn't moving.
So it has v equals zero.
But, what velocity is it going
to have just a bit later.
Well it's going to be
going that way.
So that means acceleration
is that way.
AUDIENCE: But were they given
enough time to do this, to do
this thinking problem?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so they were
given quite a while.
I think it was--
when the study on the faculty
members, I think it was a big
long think aloud protocol.
So they were given like
half an hour.
In fact, the time is
what hurt them.
Because they all thought,
oh I have so much time.
I'm going to just blast
it out with equations.
And if you were only given one
minute, you might have
actually had a chance.
Because you realized, oh I
have to think about this
intuitively.
So here, same thing
by symmetry.
And then this one is hard.
And this one is hard.
But this one right at the
center is much easier.
So this one catches
a lot of people.
But here it's moving in a
circle, and it's at its
maximum speed.
So here it's moving at
its maximum speed.
So it's not going to be going
faster that way or that way.
So its speed is actually at a
max, which means there's no
change in speed.
So you're not going to get any
acceleration in that direction.
But because it's moving
in a circle,
somebody's yanking it upwards.
So it has to be accelerating
upwards to move in a circle,
because it was going this way.
And then later, it's
going that way.
So it has to be accelerating
upwards.
So there's an acceleration
vector upwards, like that.
So this is a bit exaggerated.
It's generally not that big.
And then the question is, with
these guys, well it's just
interpolation.
It's somewhere between
that and that.
So it's going to be something
like that and something like
that, depending on where
exactly they are.
But this is the one that tripped
up a lot of people.
And in fact, a lot of people
got tripped up because they
memorize the following thing,
which is an object in simple
harmonic motion has no
acceleration at the
equilibrium point.
And that's true, except
this isn't a
simple harmonic motion.
It's almost.
But it's a pendulum.
It's not a pure spring.
So it has circular motion.
So if you reason about it
from the motion, it's
actually very quick.
But if you try to blast it out
with equations, you're
basically hosed.
So I wanted to check also, how
deep are these misconceptions?
So I actually did a survey of
students in Cambridge in the
physics major.
And so one of the questions I
asked them was the following--
so I made a survey of
nine questions.
And I wanted to see how they
reasoned intuitively on these
nine questions.
And to force intuitive
reasoning, I only gave a few
minutes to get around
the problem.
So they knew that basically
writing out a bunch of
equations wasn't going to help,
because you had no time
to actually write
them all out.
So the question was, which
is going to go
faster down the plane?
So these are two identical
planes, inclined planes with
angle alpha.
And there is either going to be
a disk like a coin rolling
down the plane, or a ring, like
somebody's wedding ring
rolling down the plane.
And the question is, which goes
faster, or which has a
bigger acceleration.
So this we'll call the hoop,
and this is the disk.
And they're going down
the same angle.
AUDIENCE: The mass
is the same.
PROFESSOR: I didn't say that.
The question is, is
the mass the same?
So I'm going to give
you that choice.
So the question is, which
goes faster in
acceleration or velocity?
So the choices were the hoop--
So to answer the question about
mass, one of the choices
is that it depends on mass.
Depends upon radius or
depends on alpha.
So it could depend on the mass,
the radius, or on alpha.
It could be the same.
The disk could be faster.
Or the hoop could be faster.
OK, so just for fun--
and I realize this is not
a physics class--
but it's fun to actually try to
guess the answer to this,
even if you're not
a physicist.
So choose A, B, C, D, E,
or F in cooperation
with one or two neighbors.
And then I'll talk about my
analysis of this problem.
OK, take another 30 seconds
and collect a vote.
Again, it doesn't really matter
whether you get it
right or not.
I just want you to think about
it, so you realize it is a
subtle question.
OK, so who votes for the
hoop being faster?
Who votes for the disk
being faster?
Who votes that they're
the same?
That it depends on the mass,
you'd like to know the mass?
Fair enough.
That you'd like to
know the radius?
Maybe 12.
That you'd like to know the
inclined plane angle?
Nobody like that one, OK.
And now who's sure
of their answer.
OK, so that's a much
lower number.
So now I can show you what
numbers came up when I asked
the students this.
So this was 11%.
35%.
13%.
This one is 11% as well.
Radius was 26%.
And 3%.
So kind of similar, kind of
similar to your percentages.
And again, only about a third
of the people were sure of
their answer.
OK, so why is this
interesting?
Well first of all, all the
students had the technical
knowledge to do the problem.
These were all physics majors in
various years, one through
four, so freshman
through senior.
But the freshman had seen the
material to actually do this
and calculate it if
they need to.
So now this problem illustrates
well first of all
that even an intuitive question
like this can
actually trip people up, even
if they've done all the
calculations.
So the question is, how
are they reasoning?
Now in Cambridge I had the
advantage of also doing
tutorials, because that's how
half the teaching goes.
So in tutorials I actually
I set this problem for my
students, and I got a chance
to talk to them about it.
So I got to figure out, how are
they reasoning about it?
So I asked them, well what do
you think is going to happen?
And then please explain why,
more than you can get just
from multiple choice.
And the answers were
very revealing.
What they said was, many of
them said, well, just as
heavier objects fall faster,
so should heavier
objects roll faster.
So that was basically to justify
they wanted to know
either the radius or the mass,
because that would affect the
mass, and that would also
affect the mass.
So, let me put that up again,
because that's a really
interesting statement.
So actually what I call this,
this is like the American
theory of the British accent.
Some of you know my explanation
of that.
So the American theory of the
British accent is that if you
go to an English person and you
step on their feet in the
middle of the nigh, they'll
actually cry out in an
American accent.
Which is to say that the
American, sort of folk theory
of the British accent is that
the British accent is a fake
that people just put on, and
in moments of stress they
forget to do the put on act.
OK, so now why do
I bring that up?
Well because it's
very similar.
So if you ask the students--
suppose you didn't tell
them this question
about inclined planes.
You just say, do heavier
objects fall faster?
You don't know about air
resistance or anything.
They say, oh no definitely
not.
Galileo showed that.
But what this shows is that in
a new situation, in other
words where they don't have
their automatic reactions, all
of a sudden the folk theory
comes out again.
They really do think heavier
objects fall faster.
Right, so how can you reconcile
that with if you ask
them, they'll say
no they don't?
Well that's because they had so
much experience with every
time they said that, someone
said, whack.
Heavier objects fall
at the same speed.
Galileo showed that, Leaning
Tower of Pisa.
So it becomes this linguistic
string which hasn't actually
been incorporated into their way
of thinking about how the
world works.
They think force is related
to velocity, heavier
objects fall faster.
And to get that to come out,
you have to, for example,
equivalent to stepping on them
in the middle of a night,
surprising them.
So you surprise them with a
completely new context, which
is the rolling.
Rolling, they haven't thought
much about rolling.
So all of a sudden, they're now
thinking about rolling.
And they're not thinking about
all the policing rules that
they were told about what
happens to heavier objects.
And so now their true way of
looking at the world comes
out, which is that heavier
objects fall faster.
So again, if you don't realize
that that's what they're
doing, your teaching is going
to be completely pointless.
And what's going to happen is
the following, which is that
here are two models.
The students will develop
two models of the
world in their mind.
One let's call it the
school model.
And another is their
intuitive model.
And let's say they start out a
bit different from each other.
And now you do a whole bunch
more teaching, and you don't
take account of the fact that
this belongs in their
intuitive model.
And you teach a bunch of stuff
about rolling down the plane.
You do it with a bunch
of equations.
By the way, I should tell you
what the right answer is.
The right answer is this one.
It actually doesn't matter how
heavy they are, because it's a
gravitation problem.
But suppose you just
calculated it out.
Well what have you done?
You've overlaid on top of this,
you've put in-- so this
is their intuitive model.
You've done a whole bunch
of calculations
which contradict it.
And the two models diverge
farther and
farther from each other.
So now next time they have to
solve a problem, they have to
decide whether I'm going to use
the school model or the
intuitive model.
And they learn, OK, well
the intuitive model
doesn't work very well.
Let me use the school model.
So the school model basically
keeps diverging.
And the intuitive model and the
school model never meet
again, which means that they
can't use their intuition for
solving any of the problems you
give them, or that they're
going to solve later.
So that is an educational
tragedy.
So the divergence, and in my
view, that is the fundamental
reason why most teaching
produces no
results a year later.
Because what you've done is
you've developed the school
model, the symbolic crunching,
whatever it may be.
But you haven't actually yanked
the intuitive model and
the school model together.
You need to actually work on
bringing them together.
So now the natural question
is, how do you do that?
So let me give you another
example of a similar
misconception and a way of
yanking the two together.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Would you mind
explaining why
the disk rolls faster?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah,
why is it the disk?
Yeah, sure.
So first of all, why doesn't
it depend on
let's say the mass?
So that's one thing to
clear up right away.
And one way to reason about
that, maybe the best way in a
physics class is to do
it by dimensions.
But another way is the following
thought experiment.
Which is, suppose I
have two disks--
let's see, I might
be poor today.
I only have one disk
in my pocket.
Well here's two disks.
The chalk is also a disk.
So now, suppose I have one piece
of chalk, and I want to
roll it down the
incline plane.
And now I ask about a second
piece of chalk.
Let's say they're identical
pieces of chalk.
They're both going to go
at the same speed.
OK, so now suppose I stick a bit
of glue on this chalk and
that chalk, and I stick
them together.
They're going to go, again, at
the same speed, as if the glue
weren't there.
Because the glue isn't
being stressed.
They're just moving
identically.
So what I've shown by that
experiment is that a heavy
piece of chalk moves
just the same as a
light piece of chalk.
So it's quite plausible from
that reasoning that mass
doesn't matter.
Why doesn't radius matter?
Well you could do a couple of
scaling arguments to show that
the extra torque you get from
being bigger is exactly
canceled out by the extra mass
because you're bigger.
So the radius doesn't matter.
Mass and radius don't matter.
So then it's just a question
of shape, which is a
dimensionalist thing.
And what it is intuitively is
how concentrated is the mass
near the center versus
near the edge.
So suppose I actually made a
extreme version of the hoop.
And actually I did this for
the students in Cambridge.
We manufactured--
and you could actually
imagine what it is.
So imagine this were
hollow inside.
That would be your ring
or your hoop.
Well can you make anything that
would move even slower?
Because I'm planning the hoop
moves slower than the disk.
Yes, what you do is you put
giant ears on the thing.
So it rolls like those dumbbell
things you do for
weightlifting.
So it rolls on this radius, but
it has these giant ears.
Well it's just going to move so
slowly, because it's just
being yanked by this
really weak force.
And it has to accelerate
this giant mass.
No chance.
So it moves really slow.
In fact, that thing it can take
20 seconds to go down a
meter long inclined plane.
So that's an extreme version.
So it rolls on this, and
this is these big ears.
So that's really slow.
That's medium slow.
And that's faster.
And if you put all the mass
right at the center, it would
be even faster, because the
rolling wouldn't suck up any
of the energy.
So that's the intuitive
explanation.
OK so now an example of a
question showing a kind of
similar misconception, a
related misconception.
But I'm going to show it to you
to illustrate what you can
do about this.
So what can you do about it?
So the question is
the following.
So that's a steel ball, which I
have in my hand, and I drop
on a steel table, say from
a meter up high.
Forget about air resistance.
It bounces off the
steel table.
And the question is
I'm interested in
the forces on it.
So what are the forces.
So here's my table.
So while it's falling, I'm
interested in the forces on it
at three different points
in its flight.
First while it's falling.
I've let it go, and
it hasn't yet hit.
At the instant that it's
stationary during its bounce.
And while it's rising.
So when you ask the students
this-- and I've done this
several times--
mostly they know it's
just gravity while
it's falling, mg.
So if you actually use this
question, don't ask--
this is chronologically next,
but don't ask that next.
Ask this one, when
it's rising.
And what you'll find--
what do you think many students
say, not all but many?
What are the forces on
it while it's rising?
Yeah, [? Adrian. ?]
AUDIENCE: So of them will
say the force goes up.
PROFESSOR: Right, some will
They'll say mg up.
I see people laughing, and
that's a good reaction,
because that shows you're
learning something about how
students think.
That's kind of amazing.
Why would they possibly
say that?
Well let's talk about this one,
and you'll see that it's
actually a similar mode
of reasoning to this.
So what you'll find
is even students
who get this correct--
so this isn't right.
It's mg down.
But there's a deep seated
misconception that if
something's moving upwards,
it has to have a
force pushing it upwards.
And then the force
somehow gets used
up, and then it stops.
OK, well what about here?
So now they'll agree that
there's weight pushing down.
So that's the mg.
And then the question is,
what's the other force?
And they call it by
different names.
In America, it's called the
normal force, which is a
terrible name.
And in England it's called the
reaction force, which is a
terrible name for
another reason.
Which is that it implies
that it's the
result, somehow a reaction.
So it's a terrible name.
But let's ask the students,
how big is this force?
OK, so it's upwards.
Everyone agrees that
it's upwards.
But how big, r or n, depending
on which country you're in?
So take a minute or two and for
yourself figure out how
big the reaction force or the
normal force is, in comparison
with the weight.
So this is a small steel ball
dropped from say a meter and
bouncing off a steel table.
So two questions, first figure
out what you think.
And second, figure out what
you think students
are going to say.
OK so you're doing both,
trying to get
into the student mind.
Let's do a quick vote.
So what's the ratio between
that normal
force and the weight?
So who votes for equal?
First we'll do what you think,
and then we'll do what
students think.
So who thinks they're equal?
Two to one?
Greater than 10, but
not quite 1,000?
Greater than 1,000 to 1?
OK now what do you think
students say?
How many say one to one?
How many say two to one?
How many say greater than 10?
Greater than 1,000?
And how many are not sure what
the students are going to say?
So actually when you ask the
students it depends on the
population.
But generally, what I find is
it's 90% for one to one, And
about 10% for two to one.
And no one says anything else.
OK so now why would students
say one to one?
What's the reasoning going
on in their mind?
Has no velocity.
So that is exactly the
same reasoning as
this, with mg upwards.
But what's interesting is even
the students who know it's mg
downwards still say, well
the velocity is zero.
So v equals zero.
Therefore, it's in
equilibrium.
Therefore, there's no
forces acting on it.
Therefore, the reaction force,
or the normal force, and the
weight have to cancel.
N equals mg because
it's stopped.
So that what I call that is I
call that the f equals mv
theory of physics.
Now maybe like in the linguistic
books, I'll put a
star by that saying
don't say that.
That's not how you translate
that sentence into real life.
But why f equals mv?
Why is it so deep seeded?
Well we have a gazillion hours
of experience with it.
Suppose I move a object,
and I push it.
Stop pushing it, and
it stops moving.
If I have a light object,
I just push it a
little less and it moves.
And I stop pushing, and
it stops moving.
So f is related to m, and f is
related to v. This seems to
explain most of our world.
It's hard to get around that.
So the question is, how do you
actually try to force the
students to see that that's
actually completely junk what
they said, and that
it can't be equal?
And the way I want to do it is
I want to do it in a way that
recombines their intuitive model
and their school model.
I want to meld them together.
So the way I do that
is the following,
which is I get a rock.
So let's call this a rock.
And I ask one of the
students, could I
please borrow your hand?
And so somebody gives
me their hand.
And I say, OK, I'm going to
put the rock in your hand.
Now, what's the weight
of the rock?
mg.
OK, great.
So what's the force of the
rock on your hand? mg.
Great.
Now I hold the rock about the
same place I'm going to drop
the steel ball, and I say, OK
on the count of three, I'm
going to drop the rock
on your hand.
One, two, and then I'm ready.
What are they going to do?
Like that.
And soon as they try to do that,
I grab their hand and
say, wait a minute.
Let's reason about this
with physics.
Why are you moving your hand?
You just told me that when the
thing bounces, it's still mg.
The reaction force and the
normal force is still mg.
And you just showed me
that mg on your hand
didn't hurt your hand.
You could hold the rock on
your hand no problem.
So why are you moving
your hand?
So then we'll have a discussion,
and many of them
will then change
to two to one.
They'll say, oh, well it's
actually two to one.
And I say OK, two to one, well
I have an answer for that.
Two rocks.
So I have two rocks, and I
put them on their hand.
So now compared to the
first rock, mg, 2mg.
So now I take the first
rock, and I'm going to
drop it on your hand.
And one, two, three.
And they try to move.
And I say wait, wait.
You just told me 2mg was fine.
This felt fine to you, right?
And they say, I know it's
going to hurt like hell.
So now what they're doing is
they now have some kind of
contradiction that's evident
between the school model and
the intuitive model.
And now is your opportunity to
introduce and explain, yeah
you're right.
Your intuitive model is actually
correct in this case.
And your school model reasoning
is incorrect.
So actually what we're going
to do is try to move the
school model towards a piece of
your intuitive model that
is correct.
We're trying to get away from
the f equals mv part of the
intuitive model and emphasize
the part that does know.
And the part that says, I don't
want to have that rock
in my hand is correct.
So then they're very ready to do
a school model calculation
of how big the force is.
And it turns out to be something
like 100,000 or
10,000 times the weight.
So it's huge because the impact
time is so short.
And then to make that plausible
to them, we can
actually calculate the impact
time or estimate it.
But then you can actually say,
look you already know this.
You intuitively understand
that.
Because if you--
again I'll stand on the table.
Suppose you're going to jump off
an object like this, what
do you do when you land?
What does everyone do?
Bend your knees.
Right, so you do that.
And what does that do?
That increases the
contact time.
And why are you increasing
the contact time?
Because that decreases
the acceleration.
The acceleration is a change
in velocity divided by the
contact time.
So you can't affect the change
in velocity very much.
That's either v or 2v or
something like that.
But the content time
you can change.
So with the steel ball,
contact time is
actually very short.
Because the speed of
sound is so fast.
So the impact force
is really high.
So yes, your intuitive
model was correct.
And now we're yanking the
school model towards it.
So you actually bring
the two together.
And you fight the divergence.
So you want to look for
examples like that
whenever you can.
And to summarize the lesson--
because it was pointed out
that I should summarize
more often--
the summary of the entire theme
about misconceptions is
that you need to understand
that so that
you can teach properly.
Because there's no way to deduce
this without doing
that, which we're going
to talk about later.
But even knowing that, if you
don't know this, you can't run
the system backwards and figure
out what goes here.
And so then, how do you actually
learn about this?
Well you've done one way.
You've done one way already.
Let me write down two or
three ways for you.
So the question is, how
to learn about s,
the students' system.
Well one way is to read.
So in many fields, there's lots
of research about what
particular misconceptions
students have.
And I've given you some of those
readings on the website.
But there's a whole vast
body of literature, and
many fields have that.
So you can look at that.
Another way, and this is--
so this is shut your mouth.
Now why is that?
Well there's no way to really
understand what students are
thinking unless you ask them.
And if you don't let them talk,
you're not going to
actually hear what
they're thinking.
You'll actually put words
into their mouth.
Because you won't imagine that
they think f equals mv.
You never would imagine that.
So you have to shut your
mouth and listen.
So office hours is a
chance for that.
And related to that is
the feedback sheet.
If students get in the habit of
asking you questions about
what was confusing, you start
to build a model of the
students' system, what worked
and what didn't work and what
was confusing for them.
So all of these ways are ways to
build models of s, which is
absolutely necessary
for deducing t.
Any questions?
OK so if you could
do two things.
One is to spend one
minute filling out
the feedback sheet.
And the other is everyone who
has a homework equation
treatment, please
raise your hand.
OK that's great.
So now just find one person
near you to swap with.
Question?
Yeah, OK.
So that's great.
So just find one person who has
one near you to swap with
and give each other comments.
And then just write your name
over the next week and bring
it in next time with you.
So basically this is a way--
and if there's no one near
you, or they've already
swapped, just make
a group of three.
It's no big deal.
Does anyone not have someone
to swap with?
OK great.
And so introduce yourself
to the other person.
It doesn't matter if you're
in different fields.
It often can be an advantage,
because you'll get a fresh set
of eyes on it.
And I'll give you some
directions by email about what
to look for and put
it on the website.
But generally just give each
other suggestions and work
together on what you
thought was a good
and what wasn't good.
And just write your name on the
person you commented on.
And then you'll bring
them both in.
You'll bring the commented sheet
from the other person in
the next time.
Or you'll just give it back
to them and bring it.
This is not a big
police exercise.
I just want you to meet
somebody else and have
practice discussing
these things and
learn from each other.
So questions about that?
So if you could finish filling
out the sheets and bring the
sheets either here or
here, I'll pack up.
And meanwhile we'll have any
questions that people want to
talk to me about individually
outside, because I think
there's another class that 's
going to come streaming in
with like 150 people.
So remember, learn about
the student system.
It's probably the most important
thing to do to make
your teaching stand
out and have long
lasting, good effects.
NARRATOR: Answers from lecture
four to questions generated in
lecture three.
PROFESSOR: So first, questions
from before.
One of the comments--
well, let's see, two of them
were that could we have less
time for questions, but also
they're very helpful.
So there's always
a tension there.
So what I'm going to try to do
is shorten some of the total
answers to the questions and
then maybe put some answers to
the questions towards the end
of the lecture as well.
I do like to try to answer
most of the questions.
And the reason being is that
it provides also pacing.
And you'll find that too.
If you find yourself generating
four times as many
questions as you have time to
answer the next time, it
probably means you did way too
much stuff the previous time.
So it gives you feedback signal
on how much material to
discuss in the class time.
And so that's one reason I'm
reluctant to just put all the
answers on the web.
Because that's sort of like
teaching with slides where you
can just flip through all the
equations really fast, and it
seems like you got through
a lot of equations.
But actually no one really
understood the equations.
So it's sort of a symptomatic
treatment for a more
fundamental problem which may
be that I'm doing too many
things and not allowing enough
time for questions in the
class itself.
A general question, which
is, how do you
evaluate your own teaching?
When you feel good or bad about
how class just went?
And what metrics do I use
popularity, covering what I
set out to?
How do I know?
So one major way
is I use these.
It's not really that I say, oh
did people hate it or like it?
I mean, I want to know if people
hated it or liked it.
And I just I don't just add up
the likes and the hates and
say OK, 10 likes minus
3 hates equals 7.
That's great.
You're batting 80%.
But I try to get a sense from
reading the comments of what
people were confused about,
what was interesting to
people, and sort of integrate
that up and imagine the whole
class as one giant
student mind.
And I want to know how I connect
the material to the
collective student mind.
So I evaluate it that way, sort
of intuitively from the
comments that people
make on the sheet.
Which is why I hand out the
sheet every time, and I think
the sheet is so valuable.
Now another way, covering the
materials I set out to.
Well I'm probably sort of on one
extreme of that, which I
don't really care how much
material I covered.
But let me explain why
I'm on that extreme.
So some people only care about
how much material is covered.
And some people are
more on my end.
So I'll give you the reason.
And most people I would
say on this edge.
So I don't need to really
justify that, because you've
heard lots of reasons
for that.
But it's the other side,
why do I not care?
Well I don't care so much just
because I think class time and
a lecture course is such a small
part of a student's life
that if you haven't connected
to the students, if you
haven't made it click for them
and got them interested, made
them want to continue studying,
then you've lost
most of the effect
of the teaching.
The effect of the teaching isn't
really going to be so
much in the class.
Because what you can do is you
can kindle interest, kindle a
way of looking at the world.
But it's really up to the
students to carry that on
afterwards.
And if you've actually bored
them, or they've decided that
this whole material is
useless, they're
not going to do that.
And then it's all just going
to go away anyway.
So actually what I'm much more
interested in is how much I've
kindled those interests.
And that's what I try to
judge using the sheets.
And I think that's actually what
produces the long term
change in ways of thinking.
Another comment was that the
rock experiment rocked, which
I thought was a good pun.
If you're not willing to write
out detailed derivations on
the board, is it more important
to have more detail
published lecture notes?
And yeah I think that's right.
In fact, that's generally
necessary.
But it doesn't have to be your
own published notes.
It could just be a book
you refer people to.
So we've sort of gone backwards
from Gutenberg.
In the days before Gutenberg,
everyone read out their notes.
That was what monasteries did.
You read out the bible.
And at the end of a year or two
of doing that, you had 50
bibles, because everyone took
notes on what you read.
That was the old photocopier,
back in say the year 1300.
And then when Gutenberg came
along the universities then
did the same thing.
That's what universities were.
They basically grew out
of the monasteries.
Then Gutenberg came along and
said, oh actually books are
cheap now, well much cheaper
than before.
Books used to cost roughly
say $5,000 a
book in today's dollars.
But then with Gutenberg and
automatic printing, they could
be much cheaper.
So you can-- and we've developed
printing technology
much farther.
So actually for a while until
word processing came along and
typesetting on your computer,
people would actually just
refer people to books and say,
OK you're a student.
You are expected to
read these books.
But now that people can make
their own notes, people have
sort of forgot how to tell
people to use books.
And instead people, the
lecturers, just tend to write
their own notes out.
And the students actually seem
for some crazy reason to
basically except notes
specifically for that topic
and don't want to read books.
So it gets really strange.
You get in these bizarre cycles
where you make notes.
And as long as you have notes
that seem like they're key to
the lecture, that's great.
Students will read them.
And then you assemble all the
notes for the very same
lectures into a book,
and now suppose
the book gets published.
The students will say, well
now we want notes again.
You can't say, well there's the
book which was the notes.
Because it's not specifically
targeted.
So part of the cure for
that is reading memos.
Or any way of teaching students
to do reading is to
shift back to taking advantage
of Gutenberg.
And then once we take advantage
of Gutenberg, we can
worry about taking advantage of
all the web technology and
word processing technology
that we have.
But yeah, it is important, to
answer the question directly,
to have the details somewhere
for the students.
And the best place generally
is in printed material,
whether in a book or in
something you write.
Because writing it on the
board is very noisy.
By which I mean that it's
very easy to mis-copy.
It's easy for you to
make mistakes.
It's easier for the student to
make mistakes when they're
taking notes.
It's best to have it all in
print, and also it's best to
put the high level stuff in
lecture, and have all the
details with the students in
their own comfortable space
when they have time to
go back and forth.
OK, so then there were several
questions about how do you
meld the intuitive model
and the school model?
Are their general principles?
So I talked about how for
example with the rock example
that the school model is that
when the rock isn't moving,
the force is zero because
it's in equilibrium.
So the net force is zero.
So the reaction force
equals the weight.
So that's the school model.
The intuitive model, somewhere
in there is an intuitive model
that you don't want the rock
to fall on your hand.
So what's a general
ideas behind
melding those two models?
So that demonstration I showed
of borrowing someone's hand
and dropping a rock on it, well
not quite dropping the
rock on it, but threatening
to, Is one way.
But what are the general
principles behind that?
So the general principles are
that you want to connect to
where all the mental
hardware is.
So generally symbolic processing
it's a sort of
surface phenomenon
in the brain.
It's linguistic.
It's only about 100,000 years
old, whereas perceptual
reasoning, visual reasoning,
visceral reasoning, those are
hundreds of millions
of years old.
Organisms have been seeing
things for hundreds of
millions of years.
So there's a huge difference
in the amount of
hardware that we have.
So symbolic hardware
say has evolved for
10 to the five years.
And perceptual, rough estimates
10 to the five
versus 10 to eight years.
So there's about 1,000 times
more evolutionary help for
these things.
So if you want to meld--
and this is basically where
the intuitive model, the
internal model lives.
So if you want to change it, you
have to connect to where
the model lives.
You have to do things
that are perceptual.
So visual arguments, visceral
arguments, auditory
demonstrations, things
they create conflict.
Somehow some kind of conflict
is also another general
principle, where you expose
some kind of obvious
contradiction.
And that's so beneficial,
because that's self teaching.
As long as there's a
contradiction, the students
know that the problem
isn't done.
So in the rock example, there's
a contradiction
between, I don't want the
rock dropping on my
hand on the one hand--
that's the perceptual view--
with the symbolic one, which
is net force is zero so the
reaction force equals mg.
So there's a contradiction.
As long as you can't get the
same answer by two different
ways, you know you still
have more to learn.
So it's self-teaching.
You don't have to wait
for the teacher to
say, oh wait a minute.
That's not the right answer.
You know on your own.
So know on your own.
You internally feel that there's
something wrong.
So you're tapping
in, I would say
contradictions and puzzles.
They're somewhat symbolic, but
they're also kind of visceral.
You feel them like oh, my
god that can't be right.
So if you can tap into that as
well that's another way of
trying to meld the models.
It's interesting.
I think it's a fundamentally
important point about teaching
these two models.
And I've never seen it
discussed anywhere.
So you're the sort of first
people to hear it officially
as far as I can tell.
So any questions actually
about that model?
Because I think it
is so important.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious, what
if you're in a field that
doesn't lend itself
to perceptual--
like if you're in a field that
tends to be more symbolic.
And physics is really nice
because it has this physical
aspect to it.
So I'm just curious if you've
thought about other--
PROFESSOR: So the question was,
what happens if you're in
a field that doesn't lend
itself to perceptual
reasoning so well?
AUDIENCE: I guess I wouldn't
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah there's
visual in everything.
And I think it's hard to
imagine a field that
doesn't have it.
Can you give an example?
AUDIENCE: Well, some
computer science.
And if you spend a lot of time
with computers, then you start
to develop it.
But you could think, well I know
that it's not possible
that it could just randomly
decide to give a wrong answer.
There has to be a reason.
How the program develops, you
can develop intuition about
where the bugs might be.
But when you're just starting
out, that's not something that
we necessarily have built in
to us in an intuitive way.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah so computers and
programming and computer
science was offered
as an example.
Yeah I agree with you.
Some fields are harder.
And what makes computer
science harder is that
computers are symbol
processing devices.
So it pushes them over here.
But even there I think
you can do stuff.
Like for example, what
you could do?
Well there are some things
like for example, loop
invariants, and you can actually
turn those into
perceptions.
So once you have get a way
of looking at programs.
You say, oh that can't be
right because it has a
fencepost error in it or it
keeps keeps decrementing the
counter, but there's
nothing to stop it
from having a floor.
So you start to see problems
like that.
And you have tools like
different kinds of magnifying
glasses to look at programs.
So you could actually
shift it that way.
And really good programmers
actually do look at programs
perceptually.
AUDIENCE: See, that's
encouragement to build up
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so you want
to encourage that.
And it's true--
pardon?
AUDIENCE: It's not built in?
PROFESSOR: I would say that the
field itself pushes things
towards symbolic.
Just because it is a symbol
manipulation device.
So that's what makes computers
so much better at what they do
compared to humans.
That's why we use computers.
Because we're so bad at symbol
manipulation, and computers
are so good at it.
So our ways of solving problems
are going to be very
different than computers.
But the problem that we have
when we're using computers, we
have to solve with
human hardware.
So when the computer isn't doing
what we want, we have to
try to find some way of
understanding what's going on.
And it can't be just purely
symbolic, because
we're bad at that.
So you can't--
I mean in desperation sometimes
you'll trace through
every step of a program and
see what went wrong.
But generally that just
overflows you
with tons of data.
It's much better to actually try
to take a step back, break
the program into parts, see big
chunks, and make sure the
big chunks work.
And experts do that, not sort
of automatically because
they've been trained
as experts.
So in any field the experts
see differently than the
novices, because their
perception is different.
So yeah, when you're teaching
computer science to students,
you want to teach them ways
that are perceptual.
You want to teach them
visceral feelings.
So one way to do that for
example is running time of
algorithms.
Different sorting algorithms
take different times.
So suppose you have-- for all
the non CS people, a huge area
of study in CS is sorting.
Suppose you have a giant list
of numbers or list of words
you want to alphabetize.
Text indexing uses it.
All kinds of stuff
using sorting.
So how fast can you sort?
Well the naive sort of simplest
thing to program is
called bubble sort.
And if you have n numbers, it
takes something times n
squared, so flip operations.
So time is of order n squared.
But then there's merge sort,
which is a divide and conquer
algorithm, which
takes n log n.
Now you could just say that.
But it's also very helpful for
students to have a feel,
because generally students don't
have an understanding of
functions is what I found.
They don't have a good
feel for what
functions do and mean.
So what's the difference between
n squared and n log n?
Well one way is to actually
program a sort algorithm and
then try it.
Try both algorithms and make
your list bigger and bigger.
When do you get fed up waiting
for the damn thing to finish?
So that's a visceral feeling.
And actually that will tell
you that there's a huge
difference between n log
n and n squared.
Because this guy, basically when
n is around thousand--
well, actually now computers are
much faster, let's let's
say 10,000--
you're pretty much going
to be fed up with that.
Because that's 100 million
sort operations.
It's going to take five or 10
seconds, maybe even bit longer
if it's written in a higher
level language.
So maybe you're fed up around
n equals 10,000.
Here 10,000 times log n.
Well, the log of anything is
never bigger than 10, as a
rough rule of thumb The reason
being that if the log of the
thing were bigger than 10, then
n itself will be so big
your computer couldn't
even fit it.
So you're not even dealing with
numbers whose logs are
bigger than 10.
It depends on the base, but
roughly speaking in base 10
logarithm, it's never going
to be bigger than 10.
So this is say at most 10.
And so if you have a 10,000
only times a 10 here.
Whereas here you have
10,000 times 10,000.
Here you can go up easily to a
million before you get fed up.
So the fed up is a connection
to a visceral reasoning.
And actually it then makes the
difference between these
really, really apparent.
So there's ways you can
do it even there.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I think that in the
science fields that, if you
really understood what you're
teaching, then you should be
able to basically put it
into a simplification.
Because then it's basically
summarizing everything, and
it's just so much better
and closer.
I mean, if you write for example
a term paper or a
proposal or whatever, you can
write a one page text
basically, or you can make a
figure or a nice sketch.
It's the same information.
PROFESSOR: Right so the comment
was that if you really
understand something, you can
make a really compact
pictorial representation.
That's generally true.
And that's why it takes really
long time to make those.
So when you're making talks,
for example, when we talk
about this later in the term,
when you're making talks and
slides, a really good model
for making slides is--
here's a slide.
This is the four to three
ratio sort of.
So here is a sentence.
So this is some assertion,
some message
you want to get across.
And here is the evidence.
The body of the slide
is the evidence.
And that's a picture.
The best is to have some kind
of visual evidence.
But what you find when you do
this-- and it is, I think, the
best way to make slides--
it takes a long time to really
find the best picture.
And even to find a good picture
because it's just so
tempting to write a bunch
of words out.
But actually if you look for
that picture and you really
try to capture the main idea in
a picture, you will be much
more successful at conveying
the messages
that you want to convey.
So in general, try to talk
to the perceptual system.
Now there was a question related
to that which is that
maybe I'm too harsh or too
negative about the symbolic
ways of doing things.
And the particular example was
so if you remember last time,
I gave this example.
So this is a pendulum, and this
is the extreme of the
pendulum motion.
And the question was what is
the acceleration vector at
these various points
in motion.
And I said, well the way to do
it is to reason intuitively
about it, to figure out what
it is here and here,
understand what acceleration
is, and do this one by
interpolation.
And the comment was well, even
if you can't do that, you can
still use the Lagrangian.
If I know the Lagrangian for
the system, which for the
non-physicist is sort
of the elephant gun.
You can solve pretty much
anything with the Lagrangian.
So you can solve it with the
Lagrangian and work out the
forces everywhere.
And that's true.
But I still maintain that
it's better to have--
I'm not saying it's bad to have
a Lagrangian analysis.
The more ways of doing
things is better.
But there's a fundamentally
important reason why it's
important to have the intuitive
way of doing it.
And that is a search argument.
So if you remember
from before, we
talked about chunking.
The experts have big
chunks, and the
novices have small chunks.
Well we looked at the effect of
that of perception, which
is that one of the proxies for
it was the chess masters could
remember whole positions, and
the novices couldn't.
Because their chunks were too
small, and if you remember
only seven chunks, which is
typical, you can't remember a
whole position.
Whereas the chess master's
chunks are like three, four,
five pieces.
And they can easily fit a whole
position in seven chunks.
Well there's another, perhaps
even more fundamental
consequence of the different
chunk size, and that is the
exponential explosion
in search space.
So suppose you're here.
This is your state now, and
you're looking for a solution
to the problem.
So suppose the solution
is here.
But you don't know that yet.
You're looking for
the solution.
Now if your chunk size
is really big--
well let's say suppose your
chunk size is really big--
you'll try a few possible
chunks.
OK, do any of those
get me closer?
Well this one looks
a bit likely.
Let me try expanding that
one, maybe that one.
Try this one.
And then eventually you get
your way over here.
So here suppose there's four
possible approaches you could
try, and because the
chunks are big,
there's only three levels.
So this gives you four to the
three items to search.
OK, now suppose you make your
chunks really, really small.
Suppose your chunks are
only half the size.
So you now at every half branch
you have to search for
possibilities.
So this is the large chunk.
So here we had one,
two, three levels.
Here we're going to have six
levels, in other words, four
to the six possibilities
to search.
So the difference doesn't show
up in simple problems.
Because you may have only one
level to go through versus two
levels to go through, and
either method works.
But when you're trying to
solve interesting new
problems, you want your chunks
to be as large as possible so
your search space collapses
to something manageable.
So you don't want to have to
reason with the Lagrangian as
the default mode.
It's fine for that particular
problem.
But if that problem is embedded
in a bigger problem,
you want to just know what the
answer's going to be roughly.
So you can continue making
progress and decide should I
go this route or this route.
So that's why I'm not negative
on the standard ways.
But I think the standard ways
are actually genuinely bad for
problem solving in
new domains.
And you want to augment your
perception so that you guide
your search in the right
direction with big chunks.
So that's fundamentally
important.
So I think that was sort of
the main themes in the
questions, and I'll look over
them and see which ones to
answer probably at the beginning
of next time.
I'll try to leave more time
for questions today, so we
don't generate so many questions
next time to
overflow it.
OK, so before I continue, any
questions about these general
principles of thinking
about your teaching?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the approach is
trying to focus more on the
perceptual way to understand
thing, but on the other hand,
the symbolic manipulations
are useful.
So how do you make sure that the
students will themselves
engage in the symbolic.
How do you encourage them to
do the symbolic reasoning
themselves without
scaring them?
PROFESSOR: So how do you
encourage the students to do
the symbolic reasoning?
Because it is important.
And I agree it is important.
Just pure perception
isn't quite enough.
I think most courses I would
say, and most teaching, is of
99% symbolic and
1% perceptual.
And it depends on the field,
but a rough estimate is I
think it should be say something
like 20% symbolic
and maybe 80% perceptual
initially.
And then as you go to more and
more advanced levels, if
you've done it mostly perceptual
earlier on, and
you've developed the intuition,
then you can
increase the amount
of symbolic.
So I think the way you do it
is you build it into the
structure of the curriculum.
So one particular course might
just have one mix.
And the more advanced students
who got the perceptual
material earlier are now
ready for the symbolic.
So there's actually a graph
that I show for this.
So that's the fraction
of symbolic.
And that's the fraction of
perceptual material as you
sort of go on in the major.
So I think this is the ideal
structure for a major.
Because this is going beyond
course design to whole design
of a major in a curriculum.
So early on, say for the
freshmen, it should be mostly
perceptual.
And there's many reasons
for that.
First of all their symbolic
capacities--
we're all bad at symbolic
capacities to start with.
As freshmen, they're worse
than the seniors.
They haven't had time for
example get sophisticated
understanding of differential
equations.
Their algebra's rusty.
It's not really practiced
much.
So don't rely on those
modes of learning.
Rely on the perceptual modes.
And the perceptual modes give
you the big chunks.
And so then once you have the
big chunks, well then sure
they're ready for the symbolic
more and more.
Because the symbolic fits into
the big chunks and helps guide
the search.
It helps actually
do the search.
I have to calculate this.
Then I calculate this.
Well each calculation you do
you need the symbolic.
So by the time they're graduate
students, hopefully
the perceptual stuff they've
had it up here.
It's really solid.
And now they're ready for
partial differential equations
and things like that.
But earlier on, you don't
want to avoid partial
differential equations.
You want to solve them
in intuitive ways.
And an example of that is early
on, when you're doing
fluid mechanics, you would
solve the cones using
dimensional analysis,
as we did before.
You wouldn't solve the
Navier-Stokes equations.
And later on, for example,
in a graduate class on
computational fluid mechanics,
you'd actually try to simulate
that and figure out what
the drag coefficient is
numerically.
So that's the mix between
perception and symbolic that I
think is a very good way to
construct a whole curriculum.
Does that answer
your question?
OK.